So, how goes it there?
It's not easy being the new kid.
Today I spilled soup and
hurt the most
popular kid in school.
Watch out!
Curtis!
I'm Ruben.
You bring soup to school?
I know you said I'm not supposed
to talk to you at school,
but something
creepy is going on.
The menu board says
come together.
I see it too.
It's your fault.
How exactly is it my fault?
Guys! We all see it.
Yeah, but I think
we're the only ones.
There's a logical explanation.
It's a ghost.
Let me know if you're still
tired after your coffee,
grandpa.
He's not your grandpa.
He's mine.
Too bad.
I don't have grandparents.
So, I've adopted him.
It doesn't work that way.
Is that...?
Mowgli?
So cool by the way.
We have very different
definitions of cool.
I'm never gonna
win this election.
Will you run with me?
Are you kidding?
Do I look like I'm kidding?
I can never tell.
Hey, that's private.
Are you and Curtis in
some kind of
secret mystery club with
Chevon and Ruben?
No, of course not.
Really? ‘Cause on
page one it literally says
the four of you were
chosen for a secret mystery.
You have to be more careful,
Donna.
We can't have people
thinking we're running around
talking to ghosts.
I don't see what
the big deal is.
‘Cause you're too young
to understand.
Fine, go ahead.
Solve the mystery without me.
We're completely
out of suspects.
There's no leads.
I think I have an idea.
Maybe we need to go to
the scene of the crime
and look around.
Of course.
It's elementary my dear.
These aren't letters.
They're elements.
Potassium, sulfur, sodium,
chlorine, and magnesium.
Show off.
I don't even know
what we should do next.
I can't believe I'm saying this
but I'm done with this mystery.
We can't just give up.
The ghost wants us to help him.
You were saying something?
I'm pretty sure I heard you say,
"Curtis was right, we
should believe him
and follow him always."
That doesn't even sound like me.
Can you two focus?
I decided to run with
you for student council.
What? Are you serious?
Yes. Now don't get so hyped up
or else I'm gonna
change my mind.
Okay. Okay. I'm calm.
We need a plan.
We need to get these
characters back in the book.
Woah.
Responsibility?
She wants us to
take responsibility?
If anyone should take
responsibility it's you.
Oh really?
Children, you must not
quarrel amongst yourselves.
Forgive me for abandoning you.
I forgive you.
You must remain a united front.
We've come this far.
We can't give up now.
When I moved here,
I had no friends.
But once I met Donna,
Curtis, and Chevon,
it changed everything.
They are splendid friends.
When I first met you I thought
you were a weird comic book geek
that brought soup to school.
And now?
At least you stopped
bringing soup to school.